well i told you yesterday that we would
be looking at this today the
rehabilitation for lack of a better term
of the biden presidency that's happened
over a period of just 26 days is quite
stunning think back to 26 days almost a
month ago gas prices were down a little
bit but not really that much we had just
gotten yet another higher inflation
report
joe biden had had a significant lag time
in terms of major legislative
accomplishments during his presidency
and many were saying
what is the game plan here what is the
justification for voting for democrats
in november what's the justification for
thinking it's even remotely plausible
that joe biden might run for re-election
in november uh in november of 2024 that
is um and you had a relatively strong
strong trump doing rallies surging
searching still with quite a high
favorability rating among republicans
and think about the last 26 days
where we have now seen a significant not
yet explosive but significant very
decided uptick in joe biden's approval
rating if you take a look at the numbers
you see that the approval rating for joe
biden bottomed out right around july 20
july 21 that was kind of the low point
now closing in on about a month ago
and since then it has been a decidedly
positive trend
not so much in terms of the numbers i
mean it's really just been a shift from
37 to 40 but remember that these are
averages among many different polls and
the direction is clearly positive
compared to past presidents you might
remember that 538 has this great tool
where you can compare
joe biden's current approval rating to
those of past presidents at this point
in time i believe were
574 days into joe biden's presidency
um
and it was below every single president
dating all the way back to truman it's
now not quite so bad if you compare to
prior presidents joe biden's uptick is
now putting himself within striking
distance of where donald trump was at
this point in his presidency
if you look at um
bill clinton uh with just a couple more
points uh biden would now have an
equivalent approval rating to that of
bill clinton at this point in his
presidency you look at reagan basically
the same that gap where reagan was more
popular at this point in his presidency
has essentially been eliminated and
biden has almost caught up there uh
roughly equal to jimmy carter and uh now
above harry truman harry truman uh
very low approval rating at this point
in his presidency only 33 and joe biden
above that so what is the reason for
this change well it's a combination of
things it's some good news for joe biden
and really just humiliating bad news for
republicans and for donald trump if you
look at the biden side the positive side
inflation reduction act
pact act
a jobs report with more than twice the
number of new jobs created versus the
expectation a wage report wages up half
of a percent in july
inflation report inflation
year-over-year coming down for the
12-month period ending on july 31st and
yes although admittedly controversial
among progressives the strike that
successfully killed al-qaeda terrorist
ayman al-zawahiri no due process of
concern to many down on the left we will
talk about that on the thursday show
but as far as presidential
accomplishments tend to go
taking out
a known terrorist on the most wanted
list
generally speaking is considered an
accomplishment and i know everybody will
get mad and everybody emails me and says
david how can you call that an
accomplishment how could you gloat about
that it might not even be legal i'm with
you i'm with you but as far as
presidential accomplishments are
concerned it certainly counts so joe
biden doing significant uh uh
significantly much to help himself and
then also you look at what's happening
on the republican side donald trump now
under criminal investigation for
violating the espionage act among a
number of other different federal
statutes his home mar-a-lago having a
search warrant served tons of stuff
taken
we learned yesterday that trump's former
personal lawyer rudy giuliani is now
under criminal investigation in georgia
we learned yesterday that donald trump's
trump organization cfo alan weisselberg
is getting ready to take a guilty plea
uh it's it's all very very bad on the
trump side so all of a sudden you have
the midterms not looking so bad with
democrats now not by much but slightly
favored to take the senate democrats
still likely to lose the house but maybe
by not very much
and at least a reinvigorated democratic
electorate now what will actually happen
in november and what is the viability of
trump and or biden to run in 2024 still
unclear
but a dramatic dramatic turnaround from
where things were
certainly 60 days ago oh and gas prices
i forgot to mention gas prices also uh
yesterday or today
ending something like a 65 consecutive
day decline all of those things are good
as far as the presidency is concerned
and yeah i mean listen
it's a reasonable thing to make the case
that actually
higher gas prices in a sense are good
long term because they encourage people
to abandon gasoline-powered vehicles
you're 100 correct if that's your view
but the narrative is the very high gas
prices are a negative indicator for the
economy gas prices coming down are a
good thing and so we have to analyze
these things not so much in the full
depth that you and i might
but in terms of how it is perceived as
far as a presidency goes and a very good
26 days for joe biden will it continue
we don't know but we will follow it
andrew yang was interviewed on cnn about
his new third party the forward party
it really went very very poorly for
andrew yang
and i i i want to kind of make clear as
we get into these clips
i like andrew yang on a personal level
he's been a guest on this program many
times i was interviewing andrew yang
before almost anybody else it might have
been sam harris who interviewed yang
before i did as far as national shows
but we were early to talk to andrew yang
universal basic income etc i like the
guy
this interview was a disaster now people
who emailed me had two different points
of view
some
like me believe that this interview was
a complete and total disaster because
andrew yang
continues to just not explain what are
the policies of the forward party others
felt that jim acosta the interviewer
bullied andrew yang and did not treat
him well i just don't see that andrew
yang and the forward party keep saying
we're not left or right but forward and
we take the
common sense consensus view on all of
these divisive issues right but you got
to explain what the position is and you
can't just be like well anything goes
here because then you're not really a
party i believe jim acosta did a good
job in this interview let's take a look
at some clips i think this is very bad
for andrew yang and as i've said before
to me the democratic party is too
centrist so when i think of a third
party which i love i want third parties
we need more than two parties and we
need to figure out the right way to to
properly bolster and inject third
parties into the national dialogue i
want something to the left of the
democratic party
andrew yang started the forward party
with some republicans
and it looks like they're basically
trying to place it between the
democratic and republican parties where
there is relatively little space by the
way
um and it just it it's not working for
me
let's take a listen to the first part of
this interview on both sides but you're
gonna have to come up with policies
negative results right
now yeah but andrew you're gonna have to
have policy uh positions at some point
how does the forward party feel about
roe versus wade should have been
overturned
well i personally
think that women's reproductive rights
are fundamental human rights but the
forward party has uh not left or right
but forward stance on even the most
divisive and contentious issues
yeah what
what does that mean i mean that that
really doesn't make any sense
his personal view is not really the
issue you have a party here and if the
idea is well
rabid anti-choicers are welcome as well
as anybody else but we're going to take
a consensus view does that make any
sense and what is the consensus view
you've got to explain it take a position
on something you don't have to take a
position on something
you can't just say well i you know this
is a hot button issue so i'm not going
to take a position on you you know you
want to run the country you're going to
have to make some hard decisions andrew
again the forward party is about that
common sense consensus majority view
which is very clear on abortion it's
clear about guns right now andrew yang
is correct
there's a very clear consensus view on
abortion by a higher percentage
than at any point during the roe v wade
era americans believe abortion should be
legal in most cases that's the common
sense consensus view
but can he not say that because the
forward party is also filled with as
many or even more republicans than than
democrats
i don't know but this isn't really doing
it for me what about assault climate
change it's actually clear on just about
every issue under the sun should 18 year
olds being able to buy areas
because of the nature of our system
should 18 year olds be able to buy
ar-15s
again the common sense consensus
majority is that there should be some uh
rules around background checks and
access to firearms but we're not getting
any of these things jim because the
two-party system does not need to
deliver it doesn't sound like you're
taking any hard positions it sounds like
you're great power it sounds like you're
you're sort of a fill in the blank party
you're you know if if somebody uh wants
a a party with no clear policy positions
you're it but unfortunately in the real
world
in the real world you have to take a
position on something yeah and this was
kind of an issue when i interviewed
andrew yang about the forward party and
i said
he said everybody's welcome
as long as they believe in like two
things
uh about third parties and i asked him
well so are white nationalists welcome
and he said yes as long as they believe
in those couple things that imploded and
later on twitter he had to backtrack and
say actually the white nationalists
aren't welcome i'm just not really
getting this i want third parties
i want a lot of the things that andrew
yang says he wants as well but i'm not
clear that we're getting it through the
forward party here's another clip where
he was asked about his kind of unusual
tweet about
the mar-a-lago search warrant
and again just everything about the
answers is kind of strange presidential
candidate andrew yang he recently helped
form a new political party called
forward alongside two former republican
officials we should know ford also
happens to be the title of his recent
book and andrew uh thanks very much for
joining us can i ask you about something
that you tweeted about the fbi search at
mar-a-lago you wrote it looks
increasingly like the fbi raid was
defined mishandled classified documents
and not some other doj investigation
which was my first thought mishandling
documents doesn't seem like raid
material it does however seem like
excellent
campaign material for trump and i have
to ask you it sounds like you're you're
letting trump off the hook here uh
taking top secret documents to your
mansion is okay with you uh are you
giving trump a pass
well thanks jim it was a very disturbing
report you just got from dhoni and the
fact is extremism is on the rise
throughout the country uh it's one
reason why we think the forward party is
so vital because we think there needs to
be
a broad positive unifying third party
movement but i'm for anything that
enhances national security and the rule
of law
and our hope is that as the attorney
general i'm for anything that enhances
national security that i mean that
isn't that a cop out like he's basically
saying
if what happened at mar-a-lago enhances
national security then i'm for it but if
it isn't i'm against it like it's it's a
mishmash
uh and the doj
dig in that the american people get a
lot of the answers that many of us are
eagerly anticipating
but are you saying that i don't think
you answered my question are you saying
that the attorney general had political
motivations
uh with this search
i trust that all of the doj employees
and particularly the fbi agents are
faithful public servants discharging
their their duty uh and it it hurts us
all
that uh people
are
singling out individuals in the way that
dhoni described it yeah so i guess he's
against fbi agents being violently
targeted uh one last clip and then i'll
give you my thoughts on something well
where for the common sense consensus
view on guns abortion climate change but
we're not getting like but what are
those views what are those positions any
of those things are just sort of fuzzy
it sounds like you came up with
something in a focus group uh you know
common sense you know middle of the
ground that sounds wonderful that sounds
great but at the end of the day don't
you have to take a position on something
well the great thing is the american
people know where we want the country to
go and what we know it's i don't know
that that's true
that we need a more dynamic truly
representative system than we're getting
right now which is why the ford party is
growing so quickly tens of thousands of
americans have signed up in all 50
states yeah i don't know i mean tens of
thousands
doesn't actually sound like very much in
a country of 331 million so i don't know
what to tell you guys like this isn't
feeling like
the
electric
injection of a third party
and
in my mind it's just sort of like okay i
know where the democratic party stands
and i know where the republican party
stands and i know that although i'm not
a democrat or a republican i'm mostly
voting for democrats because they're
closer to where i stand
if i'm going to consider the forward
party
i need to know what is their policy
position on guns on abortion on taxation
and to say that it's the common sense
consensus view
it's not enough for me to say this is
the movement for me if i'm missing
something if i'm being too hard on
andrew yang let me know you can find me
on twitter at d pacman also a reminder
wednesday august 31st we will be doing a
members only town hall where i will
field questions
for a period of time from our members
it'll be at 6 pm eastern 3 pm pacific
and you can get uh
exclusive access to the member-only town
hall simply by getting a membership at
jointpakman.com quick break right back
after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
all right an extraordinarily explosive
story yesterday the details of which we
don't still fully understand donald
trump came out yesterday and claimed
that his passports had been seized by
the fbi as they served the search
warrant at his mar-a-lago home last week
now if that is true it indicates that
the fbi presumably sees donald trump as
a flight risk
and is worried about him leaving the
country and thus they have removed his
means of being able to leave the country
that would be a really big deal it would
be unprecedented for a former president
to be unable to leave the country but is
that actually what happened was it a
mix-up did trump lie we're still trying
to figure it out it started with donald
trump posting on truth social quote wow
in the raid by the fbi of mar-a-lago
they stole my three passports one
expired along with everything else this
is an assault on a political opponent at
a level never seen before in our country
third world now
is it actually what happened we don't
really know because there was a
statement late last night that the fbi
is not in possession of the passports
now is not in possession is a statement
about the right then it's not a
statement about we never had them it
just means we don't have them at this
exact point in time
we later
uh found out about an email
that was sent from
someone uh
in law enforcement um presumably to
people on trump's side saying we have
learned that the filter agents seized
three passports belonging to president
trump two expired and one being his
active diplomatic passport we are
returning them and they will be ready
for pickup at 2pm today i'm traveling
but you can coordinate further with
whoever uh redacted copied above now if
that was indeed 2pm it would make the
statement from the fbi last night
accurate that they were not in
possession of the passports
but they had them at cert at a certain
point uh we later uh i guess this
morning got another report from nbc news
trump's passports returned after
mar-a-lago search per doj official in a
message on his social media platform
trump said the fbi agents who searched
his home last week quote stole three
passports including one that he said was
expired the fbi acknowledged it had had
the passports the same day trump said on
his social media platform that they took
them on august 8th
um a justice department officials said
trump's passports have been returned so
we we really don't know exactly
what happened here why was trump looking
for his passports how did he know that
they were in the boxes that he claimed
were planted by the fbi
i've never gone looking for my passport
when i wasn't planning to leave the
country as a sort of curiosity
it's all very strange but it does not
appear that the overall intention of the
fbi
was to semi-permanently prevent donald
trump from leaving the country that
would be a major major thing
why did they take the passports and give
them back was it an accident were the
passports in these particular boxes
we don't know but it's all very very
strange donald trump
is threatening
that his followers will do terrible
things
if the persecution that he believes is
unfair of him
continues
trump used coded language
in an interview with fox nation
but any of us who have been following
american politics
and who know what happened on january
6th can tell
this is trump saying i've got leverage
and my followers will do terrible things
this is donald trump speaking out for
the first time since the search warrant
was served at mar-a-lago
and you really have to parse the
language to understand what donald trump
is saying trump is saying
that terrible things will happen meaning
someone will do the terrible things if
you say terrible things will happen they
will be done by someone so then the
question is well who is it that would be
doing those things well it's the people
trump says won't stand for another witch
hunt well that sounds like he's talking
about his own followers and what are the
circumstances under which these people
will do the terrible things
if the quote temperature is not brought
down
what does that mean it means
if the investigations into donald trump
continue let's take a look at it because
again you've got to look at the language
to understand this trump will do
whatever he can
to quote help the country after the raid
temperature has to be brought down
so we start looking at the quotes from
donald trump during this interview
trump said the country is in a very
dangerous position there is tremendous
anger like i've never seen before over
all of the scams and this new one years
of scams and witch hunts and now this
okay so
there is tremendous anger who's angry
his followers
reasonable people who understand merit
garland
signed off on this uh search warrant
after significant consideration
christopher wray the fbi director who
was selected by trump okayed it a judge
okayed it we're not angry we understand
the legality of this search when trump
says there is tremendous anger he's
talking about his followers and he says
that it's over scams well
no sane rational person believes that
this is a scam we understand it for what
it is a legal search warrant so he's
talking about his followers that's
number one
trump then says if there is anything we
can do to help i and my people would be
willing to do that
what could that be well maybe the doj
says hey we're backing off and trump
goes to his followers and says hey
they're backing off let's turn down the
temperature
trump goes on to say there has never
been a time like this where law
enforcement has been used to break into
the house of a former president and
there is tremendous anger at a level
that has never been seen before other
than during very perilous times that's
trump linking
the anger of his followers to the peril
what what is it that they might do
trump said i will do whatever i can to
help the country
and then going on this is really the
sort of critical moment of what donald i
mean trump in the interview talks about
the fbi might have planted stuff they
could have taken anything they could
have put anything in we weren't given
access to the search but then this is
really the critical point
trump says people are so angry at what
is taking place
whatever we can do to help
because the temperature has to be
brought down in the country if it isn't
terrible things are going to happen
so understand that
terrible things will happen someone will
do them
if the temperature is not brought down
well who's running hot it's his
followers why are his followers running
hot because of the search warrant and
the criminal investigations that trump
is under therefore trump is saying his
followers
will do terrible things if the
temperature isn't brought down by law
enforcement laying off of him
look at what people are making trump do
understand trump isn't making a
prediction here trump's making a threat
as the article points out he's offering
to do anything
to turn the temperature down he can end
this he can say to supporters i lost the
election we must respect democracy we
must respect the rule of law due process
was adhered to in this search
nobody did anything wrong here other
than me
but he won't
and he wants to keep the possibility of
his supporters becoming violent as
leverage he knows it it's abundantly
clear and by the way tucker carlson is
playing it up as well tucker carlson
last night played this up in the same
language edge of something unprecedented
and something awful
you could feel it even donald trump
feels it
maybe for the first time in his life
donald trump seems sincerely interested
in lowering the temperature not just for
his own sake but for the countries
he said that he's never said anything
like that maybe he doesn't mean it
but when has he ever said that
let's all calm down a little he said the
other day and of course
tucker is not acknowledging that what
trump said is coded language for my
people will become violent if this
continues but tucker is pretending like
trump is genuinely trying to calm
everybody down that's not what he's
doing trump's trying to get himself out
of trouble this isn't good
yeah he's right
it's not good and not just for him for
all of us this could get very bad very
fast yes and it would get bad fast
if donald trump six his followers on law
enforcement fbi doj and violent protests
so
playing it up is tucker carlson and of
course everything that was done is
completely legal and kosher where will
this go in the next seven to ten days i
don't know but it's sort of scaring me
adding to the very very very bad 10-day
period of news
for republicans and maga
and former trump officials rudy giuliani
has now been notified he is indeed under
criminal investigation in that georgia
scam that they tried to pull new york
times reporting giuliani is told he is a
target of trump election investigation
in georgia
yeah
lawyers for giuliani have been told that
he's a target of a criminal
investigation in georgia into election
interference by donald trump and his
advisors one of giuliani's lawyers said
monday
giuliani spearheaded efforts to keep
trump in power as his personal lawyer
and emerged in recent weeks as a central
figure in the inquiry conducted by fanny
willis the d.a of fulton county georgia
which encompasses most of atlanta
earlier this summer prosecutors
questioned witnesses before a special
grand jury about rudy's appearances
before state legislative panels in 2020.
remember that was when rudy was flying
around doing these hearings nobody was
under oath
and rudy was farting at the hearings and
transmitting covid that's what they're
referring to
um he spent hours peddling false
conspiracy theories about secret
suitcases of democratic ballots and
corrupted voting machines
this is the latest in a widening swath
of trouble writes the times though he
got some good news which is that he's
unlikely to face charges in the federal
criminal inquiry into his ties with
ukraine
so we kind of have covered the rudy
story rudy could have spent the rest of
his days being
mayor 911
and just kind of
farting around for lack of a better term
but he chose this path he chose to
hook his wagon to the horse that is
trump
and now that path has consequences and
it's rudy's own doing
will trump say i barely knew the guy
rudy really had no role in anything is
that what's coming it doesn't seem
particularly likely but what we're
learning is that being a lawyer for
trump is a criminally risky thing to do
look at what happened to michael cohen
look at what happened to sydney powell
who has now been disbarred in a number
of different places rudy's under
criminal probe eric hirschman uh believe
eric hirschman was white house counsel
he now has been subpoenaed and you know
years ago we started joking about how
maga really means making attorneys get
attorneys it really seems to and uh
couldn't have happened to a nicer guy is
what some are saying about rudy giuliani
maybe that's the case maybe he's a nice
guy but these people do deserve it these
are not victims these are perpetrators
and i know that because of the advanced
age of some of these folks
there is a reaction among some to say
this is sad these are victims at the end
of the day just leave them alone
these are perpetrators and the victims
are the united states and its people
those are the victims and we'll see
where this goes
all of these clips you can find on the
david pakman show instagram search
instagram for david pakman show find us
there
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show marjorie
taylor green continues her brutal
assault on solar panels wind energy
electric vehicles this is one of my
favorite topics these right wingers i
genuinely don't know whether they're
this dumb or they just believe their
followers are dumb but they are
continuing this path of saying electric
vehicles are no good you can't drive
anywhere in electric vehicles they don't
have enough range we don't have enough
electrical
supply in the grid to power electric
vehicles solar power and wind power are
no good and you can't really do all the
things you might want to do in your home
if you have solar or wind power here is
marjory taylor green straight up saying
if you depend on wind turbines and solar
panels you're not going to be able to
have air conditioning in the summer and
you're not going to be able to run your
appliances check this
georgia can out just say thank god for
air conditioning
[Applause]
let's talk about refrigerators please
personally like my refrigerator i know
you all like yours what about washing
machines and
lord please god don't make me scrub
clothes in a bucket and have to hang
them out on the line
when we switch over to wind turbines and
solar panels
i'm going to be really pissed off about
that
this is a real you know the sun is hot
how could you possibly cool anything
down with solar power
this is not new okay this is a newer
version of what donald trump was going
around saying during his 2020 campaign
about joe biden's energy policy remember
this will be no heating in the winter no
air conditioning of the summer and no
electricity whatever the hell you wanted
right now you haven't made you're so
lucky you are so lucky i'm your
president
and your team is doing a good job right
so this is the same thing they've been
pulling for a while we there's just not
enough power
in wind and solar to power anything if
joe biden's president you won't have
heating or cooling by the way we've had
heating or cooling under joe biden
i can assure you
you can have everything you want with
solar and wind i have solar
it runs my air conditioning all summer
and i still get credits and cash back it
runs my fridge
it runs my oven it runs all of the
elements of my bathroom that doesn't
actually use electricity those are
plumbing it charges my electric vehicle
and i pay zero each month during the
summer and i build up credits for winter
yes in winter i use more than the solar
generates
but i've got the credits and the rebates
from the summer and i pay zero for
utilities and it's just solar now it is
true that right now
i have solar panels but i can't store
that i don't have a battery system and
this is something that's going to be the
next phase there are people who have a
battery system so that at night when
there's no sun
you're using your stored electricity
right now the way it works is when i
over produce other people get to use the
power generated by my solar panels and
then at night i'm getting power
generated elsewhere but it works out to
where i'm i'm
use generating as much as i use
so far this summer
just running everything with solar
panels i got two hundred and fifty
dollars in rebates
and i've got about three hundred dollars
in credit built up with the electric
company to offset my winter heating when
there's less sun
and you might say well what about
beautiful gas or oil heat i mean that's
super powerful and efficient right at
least for heating we should be using
those things no
electric heat pumps are much more
efficient than furnaces and most heating
systems in the united states are using
forced air furnaces of some kind they
either run on natural gas
or oil or sometimes electricity and uh
that is much less efficient than these
um
heat pumps electric heat pumps that are
there to heat a building the heat pump
will extract energy from the outdoor air
or from the ground and convert it to
heat from the house it's much more
efficient so
i don't know whether marjorie taylor
green just doesn't know about any of
this stuff
or whether she knows but understands
that she has to keep repeating these
things i genuinely don't know i mean she
doesn't strike me as particularly bright
but they are now on this really really
hard electric vehicle's bad solar panels
bad wind power bad it's all bad it's
actually all really good and the
efficiency that we would um achieve
if more vehicles switch to electric and
more homes switch to solar and wind with
electric heat pumps and induction
cooktops
would be an incredible effect now this
this doesn't mean we excuse industrial
uh carbon footprints this is the thing
where people get into well
if i just stop using straws or whatever
yeah that's very it's pennies on the
dollar um and we have to deal with
industry it must be dealt with but if
the entire country switched to these
more efficient systems it wouldn't be
the problem marjorie taylor green is
saying it would actually be really good
last night during a live stream that we
were doing covering the latest uh news
um jason whitlock appeared on the tucker
carlson show jason whitlock is uh his
background is as a sports journalist but
he's become kind of like a christian
right wing uh nut commenting on politics
and his entire appearance on the tucker
carlson show lasted under three minutes
and basically tucker carlson just teed
up jason whitlock
to
go on a very strange anti-transgender
word salad which tucker carlson seemed
to absolutely love that this is quite
literally insanity this it sounds like a
crazy person talking listen to this
beware all euphemisms
they're always a cover for lying and
misdeeds gender affirming care that's a
phrase you're seeing everywhere
including conservative media to their
great stream what is gender affirming
care well it's castrating children it's
exactly what it is and it's become
finally or it's becoming illegal in some
states but of course activists are
trying to circumvent the law
the law the rule of law
so the person behind the site or the
twitter feed libs of tick tock just
unearthed evidence of a drug smuggling
operation aimed at young children
lipstick tik tok found this online post
from someone called eli ehrlich he says
he's a phd student at uc santa cruz
quote if anyone needs hormones you can't
get access message me ehrlich wrote i
have a network with years of extra doses
now understand
the right is getting a lot of mileage
from anti-trans rhetoric if you looked
at see if you watched the clips from
cpac a couple of weeks ago in texas
the biggest applause lines and standing
ovations were for overtly homophobic and
transphobic assertions and that's why
they're all picking up on it now look
said he wants to send these drugs to
quote trans youth
now that's a crime of course but
needless to say the doj has refused to
investigate jason whitlock is the host
of fearless he joins us tonight to
assess what's going on so the doj
there is an effort to give drugs
illegally to kids that will castrate
them but the department of justice is
not interested
no they're not interested because
anything that has to do with gender
identity anything that has to do with
diversity equity and inclusion they're
all for and and tucker i'm gonna go
really big picture here but but and i've
said this before but all of this to me
is just satanic that's right guys this
is satanism it's it's absolutely sad i'm
sorry it's not satanism
it's the work of the devil is what jason
whitlock believed what a great analysis
on a major cable network targeting
of young people and children that are
very
impressionable at a very early age and
now we got someone trying to sell them
uh puberty blockers or hormones that
will change their identity and and it
all goes back to this country was
founded by people
who believed our rights came from god if
they believe that they also believe that
that belief should have nothing to do
with civil government which is a little
detail jason whitlock leaves out and
when i look at the left they want to
disrupt that founding principle that
this is a country founded on biblical
principles what he means is the left
wants separation of church and state as
the founders wanted as well
they want to disrupt all of that and
what we're going through right now
tucker is a process called sifting and
it's in the bible one of the last things
jesus said to his disciples luke this is
supposed to be an analysis about policy
understand the insanity
and tucker looks confused but tucker
likes this this is supposed to be an
analysis about policy and he's talking
about sifting in the bible chapter 22
verse 31 he tells peter he calls him
simon says the devil wants to sift you
the sifting process is separating us
it's all these different identities that
they've invented in our lifetime
cisgender
non-binary
you're a republican you're black you're
white you're gay you're lesbian you're
this you're that we're all being
separated and our founders saw us as all
coming from one creator it's really
funny
when the people espousing the divisive
rhetoric
bemoan that the country is divided it's
a real irony and even for non-believers
that founding work for all of us but as
we're being separated like wheat
we're that's why there's so much
divisiveness in this country
jason look the only person who would say
that on tv i'm grateful that you did
good wow
what what courage it took for jason
whitlock to show up on tucker's show and
give us this bizarre anti-trans
religious nuttery word salad
but imagine watching this episode last
night and thinking wow
jason whitlock really nailed it
sadly there are millions of people who
will watch that segment and say this guy
really speaks the truth and that's a
very very scary thing
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
former republican congressman devin
nunes who is affiliated with donald
trump's social media platform truth
social appeared on fox news the other
day
and he
unleashed
a dizzying array of conspiracy theories
when asked about the documents seized
from donald trump's mar-a-lago home as a
result of the fbi search warrant and i
actually am not even sure what the total
number is that this is really something
the question is about the documents and
the search warrant from maria bartoromo
and devin nunes tries to blame
obama
benghazi i mean it's just completely all
over the place
see if you can count the number of
completely unrelated conspiracy theories
that nunes mentions here and the sad
thing is
this is what the right is adopting as
their perspective on the search warrant
obama benghazi witch hunt robert
fast and furious whatever
check this out try to count them up so
so devin nunes you came out with the
nunes memo in 2018 and exposed all of
them uh is it the same documents that
they want to have under lock and key
that they wanted to get from trump's
home
well look i don't think we know that
because i'm not sure they even got a
whole lot of documents anyway they
haven't even accounted for them but
maria i would only disagree with cash i
don't normally disagree with cash but i
think this actually goes back pre-russia
gate hoax i think this goes back to the
irs scandal where they targeted
conservatives now there's all that's
three okay
the current fbi search warrant is over
stuff that trump took home
in 2021 it has nothing to do with the
russia hoax or the russia probe number
two
the russia probe was not a hoax
it actually found uh was it there were
34
indictments of individuals and three
more of companies or something like that
um and
the uh irs scandal where they targeted
conservatives wasn't really a thing it
actually turned out that they were more
or less equally
looking at organizations based on
liberal and conservative leading
keywords i mean so we're already three
con he's only been speaking for 10
seconds and we're already three
conspiracy theories in it goes back to
fast and furious during the obama
administration where they ran guns and
tried to set people up you remember
innocent americans ended up getting
killed now fast and furious was a
program where federal agents allowed
some guns to be sold and brought
uh into mexico
so they could trace the weapons
and
you can argue it was a bad idea but it
wasn't started under obama um and it
also has nothing whatsoever to do with
what's happening with donald trump right
now it goes back to benghazi they got
away with that now they didn't get away
with anything with benghazi this is
conspiracy is this conspiracy theory
five or six so far
no one got away with benghazi it wasn't
something to get away with it was a
tragedy because people died hillary
clinton was investigated in a dozen
hearings she testified under oath for
more than eight hours something donald
trump
has never done
and she was found not responsible but
again what does it have to do with this
search warrant nothing you have to
remember it was late 2015 or 16 that we
get to the plan where the clinton
campaign working with dirty cops doj and
fbi and the media i must say where they
set up to spy on the trump campaign and
ultimately republicans and frame an
innocent man that then led that never
happened
i mean in 25 2016
hillary clinton did not work with dirty
cops
and the media
to set up to spy on the trump campaign
it didn't happen this is the trump thing
they spied on my campaign i'm sure some
of you have heard trump say that they
spied on my campaign
no
what happened was
in 20 it's actually it's an it's a huge
indictment of the trump campaign what
actually happened what actually happened
is that the trump campaign in 2016
was regularly in contact
with so many people under surveillance
by the fbi
that in surveilling their targets
the fbi
stumbled across conversations with
people in the trump campaign so like i'm
going to give you an example right
imagine that
joe schmoe
is under fbi surveillance
don jr then get out gets on the phone
with joe schmoe
so there's a recording of joe schmoe's
conversation with don jr don jr is
incidental to the entire thing it's joe
schmoe who's under surveillance and
because the trump campaign in 2015 2016
was in touch with so many people who
were of interest to law enforcement they
ended up coincidentally on some signals
intelligence it's it's an insane story
but as devin nunes tells it it's
completely untrue
what so that was the russia hoax that
then led to the mueller witch hunt so
okay and again
the mueller witch hunt
led to 34 indictments of people
three indictments of companies
recovered more money than it cost
and was unable to say that donald trump
did not commit obstruction that's the
truth
of the so-called mueller hoax witch hunt
whatever it is he calls it
are we up to seven conspiracy theories
here or maybe eight this stuff is
intertwined and then you just fast
forward you know cash mentioned you know
the whitmer case and jan six and whether
or not federal agents were involved in
that
so you just stare and that's another
conspiracy theory were federal agents
involved in january 6th
there is no evidence
that federal agents were involved in
january 6. this is the inside job
conspiracy theory some people will just
generally cite it and say it was it was
an inside job it was actually some
people will say it was antifa or black
lives matter others will say it was the
fbi that actually did the trump riots
now
there is a guy named ray epps which many
on the right fixated on a guy who was at
the
at the capitol the day before the riots
and i think the day of
and um
people have asserted without evidence
that ray epps is an fbi agent there's no
evidence of that and there's no evidence
that federal agents were involved in
january 6. i think that that's eight
conspiracy theories at least
and then ultimately this leads to what
this leads to something never done in
american history before you had a
president's home ransacked by the same
goons that were involved in all of this
and i would say that that you know a lot
of people have criticized you know the
and that is not a conspiracy theory but
it's just a very dumb topic talking
point that this has never been done to a
president in american history that's not
really anything endless things happen in
the world
and at some point they happen for the
first time
no president has done the things that
donald trump has done before and so it
shouldn't come as such a big shock that
the outcomes have also been different
this is absolutely nuts eight conspiracy
theories in about 90 seconds of devin
nunes speaking
and all sorts of other deranged and
nonsensical statements like this has
never happened before and therefore it's
bad and unfortunately
they just nod along on fox news
maria bartoromo and cash patel
this stuff spreads like wildfire we
already saw it in interviews done with
protesters outside mar-a-lago repeating
a lot of these same things it's never
been done before what about benghazi
what about obama gate which we still
haven't even figured out what it is
it works and it's a circle
they say it because the followers
believe it and because the followers
believe it they're encouraged to
continue saying these things and then
it's just a circle of trash rather than
a circle of truth circle of truth is
nowhere to be found
the assassination conspiracy theory by
the way continues this started last week
after the fbi search warrant was carried
out at mar-a-lago against donald trump's
uh
at donald trump's house
and very quickly thereafter you started
hearing from some individuals that this
is the first step in a plot to
assassinate donald trump
some would say that it's a deep state
plot others said it's just a plot we now
have yet another one of these and this
time it's rudy giuliani rudy giuliani
and this is not rudy giuliani on your
screen by the way this is i guess the
the interviewer um rudy giuliani now
believes that donald trump is in danger
that the deep state may kill him
incredible listen to this said something
before in third world countries and
banana republics they arrest the former
uh
they don't kill him they kill him they
arrest them
donald trump should be in any fear of
the deepest of deep stations maybe
killing him
i do i do
the deep state this might all be part of
the deep state planning to kill trump
oh i'm just putting him in jail in many
different ways i do i mean the amount of
hatred generated toward him is the kind
of hatred we worry about that would set
off a sick person i mean if there is
anything to the fact that now
rudy is right about one thing
sick people as he calls them can be set
off
but if anything they're going to be set
off by trump and others
weaponizing a legal action by the fbi
that's a legal not illegal a legal
action by the fbi
and saying that
it's the fbi that must be abolished it's
the doj that must be abolished it's
merrick garland who's the wrong doer
that's the stochastic terrorism here now
just as a reminder a lot of people are
jumping on the assassination bandwagon
here is uh steve bannon this was last
week
and i agree i do not think it's beyond
uh this administrative state and their
deep state apparatus to actually try to
work on the assassination of president
trump i think everything's on the table
i think his security ought to be at the
heist has ever been in honestly i think
he ought to and i think he should have
flown down to mar-a-lago this morning
walked out there so steve bannon jumping
on the bandwagon this could be part of
the deep state assassination plot and
then also a guy named bernie carrick a
very very extensive uh criminal record
has bernie carrick
also doing the assassination conspiracy
theory and i just put out a tweet about
this
if you remember back in 2016 when i when
right before he got elected i was in
washington dc i was at a couple
different social events and i heard
people talking
they said the democrats want this guy so
bad that they wouldn't put assassination
behind it
and and i'm going to tell you something
they've tried impeachment
they've tried another impeachment
they've tried one investigation after
another this is about one thing
this is about stopping him from running
in 2024
and i'm going to tell you something i'm
not into conspiracies right i'm not but
here's one the
anti-government rhetoric this is the
first time in my lifetime that i would
say i am deathly afraid for donald trump
i would not put assassination
behind these people now the main thing
you know with with a lot of these
conspiracy theories
we start getting into
is there motive
is it possible to carry it out why would
it be etc etc
i genuinely have not heard one
reasonable answer to the question
if there were a deep state
assassinations plot against donald trump
why would they need to do a legal fbi
search warrant at his home as part of
that conspiracy to kill
why would you if you ultimately just
want to kill the guy
why do you get merrick garland and
christopher wray
and a judge to okay going forward with
this search warrant attracting all sorts
of attention
if the plan is just to assassinate trump
it seems completely unnecessary and you
know
nobody said that these were criminal
geniuses but it just doesn't really make
any sense if you have any answer to that
why would a search warrant legally done
have anything to do with an
assassination plot by the deep state let
me know and i'll follow up we have a
voicemail number that number is
to david p
here is a caller who thinks he knows
what obama gate is you might remember
this whole thing obama gate that started
being pushed by the trumpists during the
trump campaign uh during the trump
presidency
this caller believes he knows what it is
listen
hey david i was hoping i could uh
straighten you out on what
obamacare is yeah obamacare
obamacare is just the simple fact
that a black man got elected president
of the united states and that was the
only thing that was controversial to
these hateful racist people
and that alone is obamacare the fact
that a black man got elected the
president of the united states
so
if you're wondering what obamacare is
that's what it was all right well
there's one opinion remember obama gate
was brought up by donald trump and
during a press conference a reporter
raised his hand and said what is obama
gate and trump said you're a journalist
you know what it is
and of course nobody to this day knows
what obama gate actually is we have a
great bonus show for you today we are
going to talk about
what is happening in afghanistan now
under taliban rule this is not about joe
biden did the right or wrong thing i
believe he did the right thing trump was
going to do the same thing in getting
out of afghanistan we knew that it would
not be great under the taliban but at a
certain point it has to end
and we will talk about what life is like
under the taliban in afghanistan it's
not good
as a preview for today's bonus show
story we're also going to go back to
this shooting where actor alec baldwin
killed someone it it's it's crazy to say
it and it just kind of the story went
away but alec baldwin shot dead someone
on the on the set of the film rust
and we've heard very little about it for
a period of time we're going to talk
about where the investigation stands
today
and also
maybe in a sign of sort of conceding a
number of important races
the republican national committee is
dramatically reducing their ad spend in
a number of senate battleground races
why are they doing it and what does this
mean for the upcoming midterm elections
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show which you can sign up for at
joinpacman.com
i also want to remind you that another
great member benefit is occasionally we
will do member only viewer town halls
and we are doing one of those on
wednesday august 31st at 6 pm eastern
this will be an event
that will be streamed for everyone to
watch
but only our website members
will be invited to participate in this
particular town hall we'll do other
general town halls in the future this
particular one is a members only town
hall and you can sign up at
joinpacman.com
to get access and to participate so
we'll see you on the bonus show today
sign up and otherwise we'll be back here
tomorrow
you